donc ce rassemblement à paris devant
l'ambassade d'espagne
une centaine de militants de la
communauté lgbt se sont réunis pour
dénoncer les violences homophobes pour
rendre hommage aussi à samuel luis un
espagnol de 24 ans battu à mort aux
abords d'une discothèque c'était il ya
deux semaines à la corogne dans le
nord-ouest de l'espagne
je propose d'écouter ces quelques
réactions les assassinats de lgbt de
lesbiennes de gaye 2 bis de transe d'un
terreau sexe mais ils ont lieu tous les
ans et ils sont très nombreux dans le
monde entier en france on a recensé
aujourd'hui dix assassinats sept années
de pertes de personnes gays et donc nous
on revendique e.on et tué aujourd'hui on
est tabassé pour notre orientation
sexuelle parce qu'on ne rende pas dans
le schéma hétéronormatif hétérosexuels
et qu'il faut que ça s'arrête tout
simplement
c'est important de montrer qu'il ya une
solidarité internationale aussi que
finalement c'est aux pressions qui sont
vécues par les hommes gays en espagne
bat les un millier en france les vivent
aussi
alors évidemment c'est pas les seules
victimes de l'homophobie et de la
transphobie on pense très fort aux
femmes trans objets qui sont tués que ce
soit en espagne en france ou partout en
europe mais on constate en plus en ce
moment qui a quand même une
recrudescence de de loi je pense à la
hongrie par exemple qui sont homophobes
et qui vise directement les minorités de
genre et sexuelle et je pense que c'est
important de montrer qu'il ya une
solidarité internationale et que les
choses elles sont pas isolés et ça se
passe passer par un fait ponctuel qui
s'est passé en espagne
en fait c'est un système qui oppriment
les minorités de genre et sexuelle